[Music]
let's just jump right into
the drama triangle could you
give us an overview of what it is and
how you might use it
okay so cartman says
many of us got trained to live in a
state of victimhood and there are three
unique flavors of victimhood in the
drama triangle we call them bases
so the first base is the pure victim and
the pure victim you know it's so hard
here i'm trying i don't know it's just
any kind of a
oh help you know it's got this very
disempowered feeling and it's somehow
like they've got the power somebody else
has it not me and i'm very at the effect
of things so i could be at the effect of
my bank account at the effective this
email that just came in at the effect of
the traffic at the effect of the new
policy on going back to work at the
effect of covid all those things are
forms of being a victim
then the next role in the drama triangle
is the villain and the villain's job is
to blame
so i can blame me god i should have
known that or i should have been more
prepared or any should have over here on
me or i'm not smart enough or i can't
count on myself that's all villaining
toward myself or we can villain toward
another you know you you're the reason
why i'm not having as much fun as i
could be having or we could be a villain
to a group of people which is very
popular in our culture so we all know
who's screwing it up for the rest of us
you know it's that group over there and
everybody's pointing to particular
groups who are the bad guys
so villain's very popular because it
gets our adrenaline really kicking in i
think it's actually in the terms of
service on twitter that you have to play
that role when you use the service
anyways it's a side note
right right who's who's who's screwing
it up who's wrong yeah you don't know
you're wrong i'm right and then the last
role in the drama triangle is the hero
it's also called the reliever or the
rescuer and the hero's job is to seek
temporary relief
so
oh my god i had such a hard day today at
work let me call home i'm gonna drink my
alcohol or go might do my gaming or get
lost in netflix or whatever i'm gonna do
to give myself some temporary relief and
it works but i got to do it again
tomorrow because tomorrow i'm going to
come home potentially burn out again and
then i'm going to have to do the same
pattern so heroin
is temporary relief over and over again
so i can hero myself i could hear
another you know oh you look like you're
struggling at work and um let me take
over some of your work that you're doing
and i might do that i could do that from
a place of real presence but when i'm a
hero doing it i'm actually creating some
codependence where i keep needing you to
not be able to handle your work so i can
keep helping and then i'll resent you
over time
and then we can hear them you know
there's lots of philanthropies
especially in the past they're getting
better at this now where we just throw a
bunch of money at a population and then
next year they have all the same issues
and they need more money and nothing
ever really changes
so
the key thing is temporary relief so we
all know the story about you can give
the man a fish every night or you could
teach him to fish for himself so the
hero gives the man the fish night after
night after night and if you're off the
drama triangle you shift to a place
where you see people as empowered and
the hero asks good questions to help
people get more effective around them
so
my next question i want to
share an observation
from my rereading of the book
and then the next question just to plant
the seed is i'm going to ask you why
it's called the drama triangle what
drama actually means here
but in my reread which i'm in the middle
of right now of the 15 commitments of
conscious leadership which was
recommended to me by dustin
and i think it was also recommended in
my last book and tribe of mentors by
dustin and
there's a section that i needed to
reread which was
related to the drama triangle and it
pointed out that
the villain
could take the form of someone in a
meeting
who to try to resolve conflict or maybe
not resolve to try to
minimize conflict always takes the blame
like eventually at the end of the
meeting they just say you know what it's
my fault i should have done this this
this this and this
and it's easy at least for me to
conflate
radical responsibility
with
overly blaming myself for everything and
i i don't actually
have a great way to approach navigating
discerning those two for me if that
makes any sense yeah so so we could we
could try to unpack that or we could
jump to why it's called the drama
triangle but i'll let you choose the
direction well let me do both so the
reason why it's called the drama
triangle is because the whole triangle
is set up for a ne
you know it's i'm right you're wrong
you're to blame or i'm to blame it's
it's not asking everybody to really take
a hundred percent responsibility for how
they're co-creating experiences
so if i'm in the drama triangle the
villain if i'm taking on
i'm more responsible what happens is
i'll say oh i'm here at the meeting you
guys and look it's my fault i'll take
some of your responsibility and take it
all on me
and so
there is a place to say hey i have a
part in how i've co-created this let me
tell you my part
that would be me taking my hundred
percent and then i would also know that
everybody else has a part to play too
so i'm not taking on their
responsibility as well that's the
difference between
a villain and somebody who's who's just
simply acknowledging i have a role to
play here
you